so wait so how's your social calendar
with your kids mine mine have everybody
thinks I'm busy my kids are so busy your
kids go to school in L.A yes okay so
there's a um
I guess I grew up differently than kids
today yeah yeah so tell me if this is in
your school
this thing of like if you invite one kid
to a birthday party you have to invite
the classroom oh yeah yeah yeah that's
got to go like that's it's like I'm so
so I'm sorry I love everyone in my kids
school please I'm so sorry don't don't
hate me but it's too much it's just too
much there's always oh yeah I'm talking
about their schedule but yeah there's
social cameras for his birthdays it's
always a birthday because you get
invited to 22 kids birthday parties I
know so I used to be like you and then
we literally had a show where a little
girl came on and her mother had passed
away and she had to move things no and
and the sister the older sister to take
care of her and she was like not one
person showed up to her kids birthday
party I know so then I was like I'll we
will show up like I felt because I'm
like you I'm like how do you fit it all
in like yes the weekends are our off
times for most parents that are working
during the week anymore nope nope it's a
party there's a party then there's like
the classroom play dates and then
there's like the other plate there's
like they're very busy children so we
sometimes lie to our kids we don't lie
that's a horrible thing to say say I
don't lie to my children I I totally lie
to my children I totally I'm I'll I'm
like oh Disneyland's closed today oh my
God
oh my God yeah yeah I I don't I'm not
above it you can totally judge me write
a book on it I don't care um I totally
lie to my children I love you so much we
just tell our kids we have plans when we
don't and then when the bats live
because
[Laughter]
you know you try you teach them you
gotta you know you they have to learn no
they have to learn you can't do
everything all the time but like
sometimes you're just tired and you're
just like oh it's closed yeah so yeah we
also now have the excuse of football
which is Sunday's football Thursday
nights football Monday nights but
football's on a lot in America nowadays
yep and um so we're like there's a
football game on this college football
on Saturday why can't we go to Johnny's
House football uh I gotta watch football
see I don't get that one because I I
don't really watch a ton of football
thanks to life
that you don't do no
[Music]
[Applause]
yes
I'm going home
[Music]